die oststeirische stadtgemeinde feldbach
wurde gar nicht so auf dem platz vor der
kirche hatten zwei batterien der pk der
artillerie abteilung 5 und eine
ehrenkompanie aufstellung genommen
soldaten die sich beim hochwassereinsatz
im jahr 1959 besonders verdient gemacht
hatten erhielten die vom
bundespräsidenten verliehenen
ehrenzeichen manche hatten schon
abgerüstet und nahmen nun in zivil aus
der hand des landes
verteidigungsministers die auszeichnung
entgegen
staatssekretär risch landeshauptmann
kleiner und general drucken inspector
general major fussenegger
beglückwünschten die ausgezeichneten die
garnison in feldbach die nahe der grenze
liegt dient so führte minister graf aus
wie jede andere österreichische dem
weltfrieden kein österreichischer soldat
wird je fremden boden betreten die
soldaten des bundesheeres sind aber
verhalten und verpflichtet mit allen zu
gebote stehenden mitteln dafür zu sorgen
dass kein fremder soldat die
österreichische grenze überschreitet wir
wollen herren im eigenen haus sein und
bleiben das hintergrund und die große
aufgabe die das heer der zweiten
republik erfüllen muss in einem staat
der sich zur immerwährenden neutralität
bekannt hat